next in our countdown we have yu yu lam
lam whose furry feeding experiment
demonstrated to nearly a million of us
that rabbits rule one small japanese
island
when i saw this video i really wondered
why the rabbits were coming up to the
woman why were they chasing her you know
are these ravenous man eating rabbits
[Music]
and no this isn't rabbits rising it's
okunoshima where it's always bunny rush
hour but how do they all get here
here
this is an island in japan uh to which
five individual bunnies were introduced
uh back in the 60s you would think that
they would eventually run out of food
to survive but of course people go to
the island and take food with them to
feed the rabbits
so what is the biology behind the bunny
bedlam
rabbits have the potential to increase
their population sizes very very quickly
first of all they reach sexual maturity
at about four months old a given rabbit
could produce 40 baby rabbits in one
year so you can see that five rabbits
breeding quickly
will very quickly produce many more and
they all very quickly produce many more
all of a sudden you've got hundreds and
hundreds of them
but with a population founded by only
five rabbits isn't there a danger of
inbreeding
now there's an interesting question here
wouldn't there be a lack of genetic
diversity having a population of rabbits
that started from just five individuals
if these rabbits aren't very genetically
diverse they could all be susceptible to
the same diseases and so one disease
could wipe out the whole population of
the island but in the case of rabbits
they have a very high genetic mutation
rate so the population is probably
diversifying itself every time it has a
new litter and you can kind of see that
when you look at the rabbits gathering
around the girl on the street that
they're not identical rabbits they're
quite clearly different
and basically the only thing that's
going to limit their growth is going to
be the amount of space on the island
there's nothing to make them go away